[music]
>> Does anyone have any questions on the
introduction
of
the techniques of public speaking?
Any questions on what I've covered so
far? Brother Muhammad Idris.
Bismillah Rahman Rahim. Thank you for
the opportunity. I'm going to ask you
about the Islamic perspective
um in general. Uh when someone does the
public talk, um for example, a lecturer
or maybe a lawyer, when he argues, if he
is or she is a Muslim,
do they have to always have that Islamic
perspective? So, they relate everything
to Quran, and they always have the
Quranic verses as the reference when
they give a general public talk, for
example, in the university, at schools,
for example.
Thank you very much.
What was the question
that if a lawyer
or any expert
is giving a lecture general in public,
do they have to give reference on the
Quran? If that Muslim
is proud to be a Muslim, he will give.
I will always give alhamdulillah. Why?
Because I'm proud to be a Muslim, and I
know Quran is the best available book on
the face of the earth.
It's a proclamation to humanity. It is a
fountain of mercy and wisdom. It's a
guide to the airing.
It's hope to those in despair.
And it's an assurance to those in doubt,
and a solace to the suffering.
So, by nature,
suppose someone in medicine
asks you a question.
What do you have to do? We should come
to the techniques.
When you quote, if you quote
with the reference
that I learned from so-and-so book. If
it's surgery, I learned from Gray's
Anatomy. I learned from Bailey and Love.
When I give that reference,
it gives authenticity. Here, when I'm
talking about
anything, I believe Quran is the most
perfect book
on the face of the earth.
So, even when you are giving to
non-Muslims,
I feel it should be emphasized. Yes.
If you're presenting your case
in a court of law,
at that time you should give references
from the book of law which they follow.
If it's a Muslim country, you can quote
the Quran.
If it's not a Muslim country, you may
quote sometimes
where required.
But more important there because when
you're fighting a case for them,
for those people, for the judge, the
most important is the constitution. So,
that time you quote the constitution,
but while quoting the constitution, you
can even emphasize.
If
it's a Christian country, what I will
I'll quote the Bible
and the Quran
to emphasize on my point.
Hope that answers the question.
Yes, Farik.
As far as the impact and effectiveness
of a public talk is concerned,
the example that you gave was very
helpful in understanding as far as
Islamic perspective is concerned
regarding the alcohol example. So, how
far the matter and content compared to
the presentation of the talk in the
Islamic perspective of public talk,
would it differ? Because if a person is
talking something against the teachings
of Quran, so then the matter weightage
would but natural increase. So, how much
would you weigh in that perspective of
an Islamic talk?
Farik has
asked the question.
Have they even understood his question?
And the question he asked is
a very mathematical question
and a logical question
which
actually
disproves this
this equation.
There should be some brackets in the
equation.
He asked a question
that what is the weightage of matter and
content
and presentation skills as far as
Islamic compatibility is concerned.
Meaning
what he's asking me that okay, we
understand that the matter and content
irrespective what it is.
Suppose
the matter and content
is
five marks out of 75 and the
presentation skills out of 93 is 90. So,
5 + 90 =
Multiply by compatibility of the
Quran and Sunnah.
He's asking that what is the ratio that
you should count as far as matter and
content to compatibility concerned. And
that's a very important factor because
if you're multiplying
with the factor of compatibility.
Suppose
the compatibility ratio if it's zero,
then my equation is correct.
The example I gave matched my equation.
But
if suppose
I want to prove
that standing and drinking water is
good.
Compatibility with the Quran
how much?
Quran and Hadith how much?
Standing and drinking water
compatibility with the Quran is how
much?
No one knows?
It could be zero.
Because it says to follow the messenger
peace be upon him. What did the
messenger say?
I don't know the exact peace be upon
him. It says not to stand and water
like an animal.
This equation is correct most of the
time.
But if you want to be
more specific.
What happens?
The matter
again may be five.
The presentation skills will be 90. So,
95.
And compatibility with Quran and Sunnah
is how much?
It's haram. Because it is makrooh, so it
may be
It's not haram. Yeah, it's not haram.
So, it's pass or fail? It is pass
definitely.
It's pass.
But then if you want a higher level of
takwa, then better not
>> it is not fail. So, if your passing
marks hypothetically 50
so you'll get 50%.
You'll get 50%.
So, 50% of 95 is
Brother Ibrahim, your math is good or
not?
50% of 95 is 47 and 1/2%.
So, total becomes 47 and 1/2, which is
also correct. What he wants to ask that
do you multiply with the same factor?
Do you multiply with the same factor?
And the answer generally is yes.
But if you really want to split hairs,
then you can say okay, the factor of
multiplication of the matter in Islamic
perspective should be more as compared
to the presentation skills. If you want
to split hair and be very specific, but
generally, even if you add both
together, the matter and the
presentation skills put together, and if
you multiply, I give an example of
standing and drinking water because
standing and drinking water, most of the
Muslims think is haram because Muhammad
said,
there are various hadith in Bukhari and
in Muslim that do not stand and drink
water. Sit and drink. This is the
commandment of the prophet.
But there is a hadith also in Sahih
Bukhari.
Volume number seven, book of drinks,
hadith number 5615,
which says Hazrat Ali, may Allah be
pleased with him,
he stood and drank water
and he said, "I know many people think
it is wrong, but I've seen the prophet
stand and drink."
So, when there is a commandment
contradicting with an action,
if the commandment is don't do,
then doing it is not haram, it is
makruh.
It is not prohibited, it is discouraged.
And in Islam,
anything what you do is makruh, you
don't get negative points.
But you lose your positive points.
You get positive points. So, if I don't
stand and drink,
if I sit and drink, I get positive
points. But, if I stand and drink, I get
no negative points.
So, when you are trying to prove
something which is makro and use the
presentation skills, etc., so your
Islamic perspective will not be zero,
would be 50 or maybe 40, whatever it is.
So, in this time, when you add both, yet
the total would be somewhat similar.
Because presentation skills maximum can
be 93. Matter can be 700. Even if it's
100% because it's multiplication, it's
not addition.
Yet, the total answer will not be wrong.
So, don't have to split
the matter separately and the
presentation skills separately. What I
did is to be more safe,
I have to put brackets here.
Go to the maths. You know because
Alhamdulillah, I love maths. Though my
son doesn't like maths.
If I put a bracket here,
then no one can take out a mistake in my
equation. So, put a bracket in front of
matter and close the bracket
after presentation. Do you know what is
the difference between the first and the
second?
I said correctly. But, here,
this sentence can have two meanings.
Matter and content plus presentation
multiplied by compatibility of the
matter and presentation Quran and Sunnah
getting it. If I take matter and content
as five
and presentation is in 90 multiplied by
zero, so it becomes five plus zero, my
Islamic effectiveness becomes five.
So, if I put a bracket,
no mathematician also can take out a
mistake.
My explanation was right.
But the notes
had a problem.
Have you understood?
Who knows the rules of BODMAS?
1 2 3 4
You don't know BODMAS?
BODMAS brackets off
BODMAS is an acronym that when we
learned maths, at least when I learned
in school
most of you may have done the same.
BODMAS like when you have a mathematical
equation, how do you solve it? First is
brackets off.
BO brackets off D is division, then you
do division. Then do multiplication.
Then do addition, then do subtraction.
Is that clear?
BODMAS So if the bracket is there
it is very safe.
So first you solve the brackets, that is
matter
plus presentation [snorts] skills.
So you join it.
Then you do the multiplication. Then the
answer will always be zero if it's not
matching Quran Sunnah. But if you can do
only matter
okay 5%
plus presentation skills
So presentation skills multiplied by
authenticity of Quran and Sunnah.
So my explanation was right.
But in the notes if you put brackets
it is secured.
You're not allowing anyone to punch
holes into it. Those who know will
understand.
But when we are giving a talk always see
to it that we secure ourselves and
prevent anyone punching holes
like what my son asked me now.
If the brackets was there it would have
been clear. Because brackets are not
there he's asking now.
No one asked this question in the past
few thousand any program that we had.
It's the same notes that's circulating.
So just make that change.
La
ilaha illallah
la
ilaha illallah, [music]
ilaha illallah,
Muhammadun
rasulullah,
Muhammadun [music]
arju ridhaka ya Allah, anta rahimu ya
Allah, hab ni ataka ya Allah, antal
karimu
minka afwu ya Allah,
antal adhimu ya Allah,
fika raja'u ya Allah,
antal halimu
>> [music]
[music]
[chanting]
>> ar-rahmanu as-sattaru [music]
malikul mulkil ghaffaru al-wahhabu
al-mannanu al-muta'ali
Allahu Allahu ya rabbi ya Allah,
Allahu
ya rabbi
ya Allah